I once read that you know even though
most of us watch television and and and
see motion pictures that we remember our
lives and still frames we remember
movies and still frames that's how our
brain works so I think making a very
powerful photograph can affect a
person's life and I think that for me
doing stories and making pictures
particularly these days about the
environment and about the problems that
are going on on the ocean can indeed
make a difference I think that you know
the first step in making change in
anything in the world is awareness we
have to be informed and that can come
through photography I started with an
interest I guess in the ocean from the
time I was a very young boy I can
remember being in my parents living room
looking at the pages of National
Geographic magazine and dreaming about
being an adventurer being about one of
those people that was going to exotic
places and doing cool things and as I
got a little bit older I guess about age
15 or so I started to use scuba gear so
I started out as a diver first although
I always had an interest in photography
it was more for me in the beginning
about the exploration about being that
adventurer however I was you know a kid
that was probably 17 years old 18 years
old living in a small town in
Massachusetts kind of a blue-collar town
and the notion of somebody like that
becoming a National Geographic
photographer let's say specifically
underwater was probably a one in a
billion chance I don't know why I didn't
give up along the way there certainly
were many days where I would come back
and look at a roll of film that I shot
and say this is terrible and you know
what am i doing I mean I could be making
great money and and driving nice cars
and living in a good home and instead
I'm you know I'm pursuing this artistic
dream there was just something inside
there was just something within me that
didn't allow me to quit I don't know if
it was stubbornness or stupidness or
what but I just couldn't give it up I
didn't want to be you know very old and
thinking back saying I didn't
the chance eventually I got my first
assignment from National Geographic ten
years later I'm working on my 16th story
for the magazine and it's been fantastic
and you know I finally got to do those
things that I always dreamt about doing
when I'm on assignment I generally have
an idea of what it is I want to do long
before I've arrived in whatever location
I'm working I've given a lot of thought
a lot of research to the subjects the
animals the people I'll be working with
and how I might approach that subject
you have to be loose of course you have
to allow for changes or serendipity
which can often add great things to a
story but when I'm physically in the
water hopefully working with the subject
I have in mind I'm trying to think about
many things I'm trying to think about
how the light is affecting my subject
light is everything of course and in
photography and that usually means I
have to bring my light with me for
example into the ocean because you know
colors get lost very quickly underwater
so I have to bring down into water
strobes and I've got this big housing so
I'm physically trying to manage all of
that and I'm thinking about f-stops and
apertures and getting the exposure just
right and I'm thinking about the animal
you know is it too close is it too far
away am I in a threatening situation so
many things are thinking about but at
the end of the day you know you you hope
that you're going to be experienced
enough or you've got enough salt
only about three three and a half years
ago did I made the make the switch to
digital photography and I sort of
dragged my feet I was a little reluctant
about it I wasn't sure the quality of a
digital imaging and I I didn't know that
you know that this would be as good as
film but once I made the switch I can't
imagine going back we used to go on
assignment shoot four or five hundred
rolls of film come back send it to
Washington DC to National Geographic
headquarters I'd spend two weeks waiting
for the phone call and then they'd say
you did good or well it's not some good
and you know it's it's nerve-wracking
but now I know what I've got before they
do so in the old days and not that long
ago I think failure was a much more
ready partner there was always that
angel of death on your shoulder waiting
to to pounce because things were always
so stressful now you know you've got a
little more latitude you can do more and
I think the failures or less because
you're seeing how you're doing it's like
being in a studio and we learn from that
we learn a tremendous amount I think
I've become a much better photographer
than the last three and a half years
because of that technology because I've
been able to see instantly how I'm doing
I think curiosity is is a great tool to
possess that and patience of course as a
photographer I am interested in
everything I mean I love everything and
I'm fascinated and interested in all
animals so when I propose stories to the
geographic I'm just looking for a good
story in 2003 I published a story with
National Geographic about something
called the Aquarius habitat which is the
world's only laboratory for scientists
underwater it's actually this little
house if you will on the bottom of the
ocean perched at about 60 feet off of
Key Largo Florida where scientists and
in my case journalists can live on the
bottom of the ocean and this was a
week-long mission to study the benefits
of marine protected areas but the
experience was amazing I mean most dives
you're limited to maybe an hour
underwater but here I was able to spend
six or seven hours
and what that meant was that you could
see things you could acclimate to some
of the animals in a way that I never was
able to do before
it's very cool it's something that you
know as a child I remember looking at
you know futuristic drawings of what the
world might be like when when I got
older and this was sort of what it was
about it was you know having this moon
pool that you could kind of emerge into
from from the ocean and then dry off and
you're living underwater and their
review ports and before you go to bed at
night you can watch a shark swim by
literally saw a shark swim by one night
before bed and schools of fish out in
the spotlights there were evenings where
I'd go and just sit out on top of the
habitat the physical hull and just watch
this transition that occurs on the coral
reef from day to night where you know
huge schools of fish would be sweeping
past as they go to find their protection
for the evening and other animals would
kind of emerge and come out as the dusk
began to set and all of these things
couldn't photograph necessarily but what
an exceptional experience there's all
kinds of stories behind the scene if you
will that go into an assignment you know
I guess the ones that a lot of people
like to hear about of the the kind of
scary ones or the the Indiana Jones
moments if you will I've had my share
I've been diving in Canada one day when
I surfaced in a snowstorm actually to
watch her a dive boat it was an old
fishing boat sinking I did a story in
Ireland where the dive boat didn't see
my assistant and I after we surfaced and
we drifted away in the middle of the
Atlantic we were drifting for two and a
half hours and the chilly North Atlantic
ultimately got picked up by a fishing
boat that happened to pass by I've lost
my way inside shipwrecks like the Andrea
Doria or underneath Arctic pack ice for
a few moments and been disoriented under
there and you know you could feel your
your heart beating and the stress
beginning to mount so there's all these
things you know I've been nipped by
sharks and chased by sperm whales and
you know been grabbed by a Humboldt
squid and the Sea of Cortez and two
o'clock in the morning there's all these
exciting moments but truth is what I
prefer to think about or all the
wonderful moments the the fact that in
underwater photography especially unlike
terrestrial photography we can't use
telephoto
Lenz's let's say to get close to our
animals so we physically have to get
close to these subjects which is a
testimony to these animals you know that
animal had to choose to get close and it
never ceases to amaze me when I go on
assignment you think about the odds
against you of getting these pictures
all the things that have to line up and
somehow miraculously they do they always
seem to happen you know I just did a
story on right whales and I went to a
place on the planet that these were
animals had really never been
photographed before was an island a
group of islands in the sub-antarctic of
New Zealand and it was a population that
had only been discovered about ten years
ago didn't know how these animals would
react got there in the middle of
wintertime in the sub-antarctic with
wind blowing and clouds and snow got in
the water and these forty five foot
whales swam over to me I mean within
inches they were curious about me those
kinds of moments of the other ones that
I think we should celebrate those are
the moments that really I'm hoping to
remember in my old age because those are
the ones that made the difference you
know the exciting dangerous moments are
there and but they pale in comparison to
the to the real highlights
so much of the ocean has not really been
explored it certainly hasn't been
photographed so this is what I'm looking
forward to down the road there's
absolutely so much more that I wanted to
I I just you know I don't sleep at
nights because I think about all the
great things that I want to be out there
doing I may have had a wonderful run
these last thirty years but I'm probably
most excited about the next 30